VELY TO ENHANC
AND ACCELERATELIKE THELA OF
THILRENCE TO
THEPR
EN
LOWERIRESCRIG COS ST, UNIVERSAPN
.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BLAMG THAN WESTA
MANCHIN.
YOU THINK IT'S FAIR FOR HIM TOP?
>> DH TE
THOSE PRIORITIES ETE REPUBLICALN
ALSO WHERE BEEN ABLE TO
T A LOT NETHE EFFECT OF THICAN
NOW, THE BIPARTISAN LTN IES ACRA
INFRASTU THAT'S
ENABLI MTMENOTHERS TO MA IMPROVT
ACROSS THE COURYN EVERYTHINGPORE
THE E
ENAV'TN EVERYTHING WE S ANDMINI.
CONTINUING TO
PUSH OHETIES. OVERLOOK WHAT'S
EVEREL PUSHING FOR WT NEEDS I'M
SEEIHEE TO GET
SC
THAT WLDA LOT OF G ROOM FOR FAM.
TO BE
DONE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF
BUNGZ CHENEY SPOKE DIRECTLY TO
REPUBLAN THEEN
ABN HER VIEW T
CODIFY PROTECTIONS FORSEX
MARRIAGE.
UBLICAN SE
TO M
ND CALLEYOU HE'S GOIO
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGTO SENATE
REPUANF HE'S GOT TIME TO FIGHT
THIS IREALLYOR A
CORTANT TO .
I STARTED MYAS I TRY TO DO
PARENTSM.NG, AS EVERY ND DEAKFA
IT WASOSE DAYS
BUNOHES TO GIVE ME EH TI TO  THR
CHOP UP THE BANANA ANDHE
FORMULREADY.
TH HUR OF MY MORNING HAD
ME
O M
ERVES TOTED DON'T  THI
HA SENATOR OA NGRESSMAN --'T
UNDERSTAND HOW SUCH A JO
OF HOUSEEP VOTED NO ON
WASN H G
ABOUT TRANSPORTATION POL
T I THOUGHWERENORMALVERSATM ON
SUAROUNDANSAAT
MY MARRIAGE DOESN'T DESERVE TO
IF THEY